we don't teach leaders how to have
uncomfortable conversations we don't
teach students how to have uncomfortable
conversations you tell me which is going
to be more valuable for the rest of your
life how to have a difficult
conversation or trigonometry
described as a visionary thinker with a
rare intellect multiple time
best-selling author science cynic
every single one of us knows what we do
some of us know how we do it but very
very few of us can clearly articulate
why we do what we do and i think one of
the reasons most of us don't know who we
are is because we're making decisions
that are inconsistent with that true
cause with that why there's a great
irony in in all of this
i had what a lot of people would be
considered a good life and yet didn't
want to wake up and go to work anymore
why
i
we cannot do this thing called career or
life alone we're just not that smart
we're not that strong we're just not
that good for anyone who wants to be a
better version of themselves purpose
comes from
it's one of the best podcasts i've ever
done
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
direva ceo usa edition i hope nobody's
listening but if you are
then please keep this yourself
[Music]
simon
my introduction to you was this book
start with why and it hung on the walls
of some of my offices around the world
for a long time and then my employees
would come in after reading the book and
evangelize about it and it would come up
in meetings and in discussions and in
creative brainstorms etc over and over
and over again the question i wanted to
ask you was
was there a point in your life where
you'd felt
like you drifted so far from your why
that you realized the importance of it
for the first time
well the simple answer is yes um it was
that drifting
that set me on the
path to find it in the first place to to
even articulate that idea
i had what
a lot of people would be considered
sort of a good life as living the
proverbial american dream
you know i
quit my job to start my own business the
business was doing okay made an okay
living had great clients did good work
and yet i'd lost my passion for that and
didn't want to wake up and go to go to
work anymore
which was embarrassing because
superficially everything was just fine
i was pretending that i was happier more
in control and more successful than i
was or felt
um which is quite frankly pretty
draining and pretty dark
and it wasn't until a very very close
friend of mine came to me and said
something's wrong she was the first one
to notice something
and i came clean
and i sort of
let it all out
and uh it was
that catharsis that sort of lifted this
heavy weight off my shoulders i was no
longer alone it was no longer a secret
um and all of the energy that was
previously going into lying hiding and
faking now went into finding a solution
there
was a confluence of events it's not you
know all of these histories are
perfectly neat and
clean and that's not really how it is or
was
but
to compress it and oversimplify it i
made this discovery based on the biology
of human decision making that every
single one of us knows what we do
some of us know how we do it but very
very few of us can clearly articulate
why we do what we do and i realized that
was what i was missing so to answer your
question
yes 100 the realization of the why was
my loss of it and i realized i knew what
i did and i was good at it i knew how i
was different or special or stood out
from the crowd and that was my
differentiating value proposition and i
was articulate about it but i couldn't
tell you why i was waking out of bed
every day to do it you know and i would
give some
nonsense entrepreneur answer because i
want to be my own boss and be like yeah
sure but that's not a reason to get out
of bed every day this got me thinking a
lot about
the guests that i have sit here and also
my own story where
sometimes
i think people's why or the thing that's
been driving them is in fact some kind
of trauma or insecurity
i think because you sit here with people
in there
whether it's
israel arasanya the ufc champion who's
the current
maybe world's best ufc fighter he was
battered and bullied as a kid being the
only black kid in his school in new
zealand and so it's no coincidence that
he strived to be this fighter and in
fact when he won the ufc title the next
day he was he was depressed and he went
to therapy
that's made me question whether like our
wise can sometimes be
trauma or
insecurity driven as opposed to being
intentional in i don't know
so a why
is fully formed by the time we're in our
mid to late teens the youngest person
i've done at wide discovery 4 was 16 and
it worked the process worked
um
and what i've learned from just doing
hundreds of these over the years
is that a y is always positive it's
always striving for something so like
we're not inspired against something
we're not inspired to stop something
we're inspired to build something or
create something or advance something
though it may have been born out of
trauma
there's usually a silver lining that
gives us that cause especially trauma
that happens in the middle of our lives
you know september 11th is often looked
to as you know people found purpose
you know we are who we are
like i said we're fully formed by the
experiences we have when we're young
you know at a pretty young age
and now the opportunity life presents us
is to make decisions that either keeps
us in balance with who we really are or
not and i think one of the reasons most
of us feel discomfort or don't feel
ourselves or don't know who we are is
because we're making decisions that are
inconsistent with that true cause with
that why so you raise
the case of
um individual athletes who become
champions and then suffer depression
it's a
fairly common story you hear this from
olympians you know michael phelps
becomes the most meddled you know
uh olympian of all time immediately
suffers depression andre agassi becomes
the most storied you know tennis player
of all time immediately becomes
depressed
and
what i've learned from talking to some
of these
um
these particularly athletes but i think
it happens in the business world as well
which is from a very young age
they set themselves a goal
that
in my words would be a very selfish goal
i want to be the best at x the best
tennis player the best golfer the best
whatever and you know the way olympians
put it which i get a kick out of is i
want to win the olympics like well
no one wins the olympics like you can be
a winner in your sport you know but
that's an aside
but and and their entire lives from
pretty young ages
every decision they're making
is to help them advance this finite goal
all of their relationships
are can you
help me achieve my goal
right and if you can no longer help me
achieve my goal i don't need you anymore
as a coach
or even a friend
and there's huge sacrifices missing of
birthdays missing of christmases you
know missing of major life uh events
because i have to practice so i can
achieve my goal and when they get
interviewed on the news
you know or at the olympics or whatever
you know why do you do it they'll say
well i'm doing it to inspire the little
kids which is complete [ __ ] you know
if you look at all of their
vision boards from when they were
younger
of pictures of podiums and medals and
money and lamborghinis not a single
little child on there of the people
you're doing it for it's it's just a
lucky strike extra i mean absolutely you
do inspire children but that's not the
reason you did it you just got that you
know like i said it's sort of a it's a
twofer
and
and then when they achieve or don't
achieve this thing and then can no
longer compete for it
um
they've set their entire path and all
their relationships on this one these
finite selfish goals and so when it's
complete
they realize they don't really have a
lot of friends around them they don't
really have a lot of close relationships
they don't really even have a sense of
purpose because they've been spent the
past 20 years or so with one purpose
which was this finite goal which now has
run out
and so the very purpose lists
and i see this in broadway performers
who set their whole life to be on the
west end or be on broadway
you know every class every tap dancing
class every singing class they make it
they get there and then
depression or at least malaise
or senior executive same thing if i just
or if i just make a million dollars
you know if i just become a millionaire
then i'll feel
and uh and the problem with all of those
things is as i said before they are
selfish
uh it is your goal for your reasons
which
um
is not fulfilling for any social animal
for any human being
you know our sense of joy and
fulfillment and love
and purpose
comes
from our ability to serve another human
being have a child tell me how your life
changes
fall in love tell me how your life
changes you know think about all the
stupid things irrational things we've
done for love we get on planes and
travel around the world just to say i
love you you know we do ridiculous
things and it all feels worth it
and the sacrifices we make for a child
all feel worth it but these are no
longer for us and these things will live
on beyond our own lives they are not
finite they are infinite
and there's nothing wrong with personal
achievement there's nothing wrong with
setting goals
but it has to be in the context of
something even bigger
in general
team sports don't suffer this because
you had to do it together you know it's
usually individual athletes who suffer
this more often uh and so there is a
there's one of the athletes i would
point to is a guy by the name of curtis
martin
curtis is a
hall of fame nfl footballer um
and
he only started playing football
basically to stay out of trouble
he did it as a favor to his mom
just so he wouldn't get into he grew up
in a really bad neighborhood in
philadelphia
it basically kept him out of trouble it
turns out he was really good at it and
when he realized he was good at it he
realized that by being good at something
it will give him the power to actually
give back later and
he made this realization especially when
he went to college on scholarship and
then made it to the nfl he realized the
better he was at the sport it wasn't
about propelling his own career it was
about when he leaves this career he has
a platform
that would be bigger than the platform
he has now and so he was driven and
driven and driven not so that he could
be the best not that so that he could
make the most money in fact he made a
lot less money than a lot of other
players of his rank
not that he could uh
be rich or famous or any of these things
he did it so that he could build his
platform so he could give back later so
when he retired from the nfl
he wasn't lost he wasn't searching
he he knew exactly what the next step
was because
being in being an elite athlete to the
highest level possible was only step one
um and to see one's life as a continuum
rather than a than an event
um is much healthier
on that point of seeing one's life as a
continuum by the way you completely you
call it atting someone where you
describe their situation but you
completely added me you completely
described my situation in terms of
the place of mind i was in at 25 when i
had that offered to buy my company
it was about me it was about filling
some void that i had in me from
being like the only black kid in an
all-white school and thinking that i
think
success and
accolades would fill that void in some
ways but on that point of a continuum as
a as a way to live your life the other
moment in my life where i which i really
struggled in terms of goal setting and
motivation was when i was trying to get
in shape and in like 2017 i said to
myself i want to get a six-pack for
summer that's the goal i set myself
really what i was trying to find a way
to stay fit forever but i set myself
this goal of getting a six pack in
summer that was my thing and then every
single year my motivation would only
last for like four or five months and i
couldn't crack how people are
continually motivated to work out
i've cracked it now but what was wrong
about that because i've heard you speak
about arbitrary goals before what is the
the flaw of creating arbitrary goals in
our lives and how do we create goals
that are more based on that idea of a
continuum
you know i i'm not a huge fan of the the
term self-improvement right
um but i do like
the idea of awareness
self-awareness
you know we all live with blind spots
we all
live with missing gaps and pieces of
information which will by the way last
for the rest of our lives and there are
some people who choose to live a life
where
living with those gaps is acceptable and
they never fill them in and we would say
that they remain stagnant
and arguably
either mentally or physically unhealthy
or
gaining
you know getting unhealthier as they get
older you know
for someone for anyone who who wants to
be a better version of themselves
a more aware version of themselves you
you
we i seek out
information
and that comes in all kinds of forms
right it can be in a relationship
um so for example i went and took a
listening class
or actually i should pre preface with um
i was dating someone
and she accused me of being a bad
listener
and i was like
you do know what i do for a living right
like
i'm a really good listener so i don't
know what you're talking about you know
and then i took this listening class
turns out i'm an absolutely
brilliant listener
with people who i'll never see again for
the rest of my life
but amongst my friends and family
appalling
appalling
so i had this basic skill set that i
never applied
with the people closest to me
and gave myself an out because quote
unquote i knew how to listen
um and so i realized i was a terrible
listener this was a blind spot this was
a gap and having somebody love me tell
me that didn't work
didn't believe them
until you know this objective outsider
or at least i just took this class and
came to this realization
that was brilliant that awareness
of the blind spot and the awareness of
the skills that i need
to be a better brother son boyfriend
friend
you know
i had to learn how to hold space for
someone
and then practice
um that's awareness
and i think
our health is awareness unfortunately
some people wait for the
breakup to learn that they're bad
listeners some people wait for the heart
attack to realize they're eating poorly
you know that's awareness you get
awareness by getting a punch in the face
and i think i think it's a
responsibility for every human being
should they want to have value in the
lives of others
to seek awareness in how they show up in
the world and and how the world impacts
them
their mental health their physical
health their ability to maintain
relationships and nurse relationships
and you hear me what you i mean you
heard me say this over again it's a sort
of it's a it's a repeating pattern which
is for those who want to show up better
in the lives of others
which is i see being healthy as a
service to others
i see being a better listener being a
service i see everything in terms of
service to others there are benefits to
you as well of course
but i i think we've neglected for
decades
the socialness of our animal and social
media and cell phones and and the
ubiquity of those technologies have
complicated our ability to be human
um
there are others who comment on this as
well brene brown talks about this
where we have a young generation
that has mistaken vulnerability and
broadcast
right
where
you sit in your room
by yourself
put your phone on record
and make a video of yourself crying
because of the loss of a relationship
and then posting that on instagram or
snapchat or youtube or
tick tock or whatever your
media of choices
and
the hashtag is just being vulnerable
right and there's nothing vulnerable
about that you're by yourself
broadcasting to the world live or
videoed it doesn't matter
do that exact same thing
with the person you hurt
that is way more difficult
don't leave a voice memo saying hey i'm
really sorry just taking accountability
call them or go visit them and look them
in the eye and say that exact same
sentence that you just left a voice memo
for
that's vulnerability that's really hard
and requires practice and we avoid it
because it's difficult
we avoid it because it's uncomfortable
we choose broadcast not because it's
better it's because it's easier
and then mistake the two
and so
the reason to learn to be vulnerable is
not for ourselves it's for our service
to others and i talk about this all the
time which we've confused these things
and once again going back to what we're
talking about before we've weirdly taken
these very pro-social activities and
made them selfish
like go us
my biggest pet i'll give you my biggest
pet peeve and i've talked about this one
before but it drives me nuts
i was at this me i was in this meeting
once
and there was a
woman next to me who was this big timey
yoga instructor apparently
and the entire meeting was a
big group of us she was on her phone
under the under the desk under the table
and i sort of sneaked over a look and
it's not like she was like there was a
family member in hospital and she wanted
to just you know stay in touch
she was on social media i could see
right
and at one point the conversation at the
table turned to being present
and she popped up her head and said
that's why i love yoga because it helps
me be present
of which i'm thinking you're an idiot
you know
and i started to realize we've confused
things here which is
we don't get to decide when we're
present we get to practice being present
but you actually are not present until
someone else says you are
you know
you don't get to sit with a friend and
be like i feel present if they don't
feel it that's like me saying i'm a
great listener except i'm not
right i don't get to self-assign
these accolades
especially when they're social
they can only be assigned by another and
so for anyone who's ever practiced
meditation there are absolutely benefits
to us without a doubt
and it is in those are important
mental and physical health benefits of
meditation and mindfulness and we should
practice those for sure
but there's also that
what i think is the primary reason some
would consider secondary reason
which is if you practice meditation for
example you learn to focus on one thing
your mantra a sound whatever it is you
learn to your breath you learn to you
don't nobody you don't think of nothing
you think of one thing you focus on one
thing right and if something interrupts
that thing you have a thought
can i leave the washing machine on
you know
you label it a thought
and you push it out of your head and you
say i'll deal with it later and that's
the whole the whole idea his total focus
and the ability to put your thoughts out
of your head to stay focused on this one
thing
now think about when you're sitting
listening with a friend who's going
through a hard time
are you listening are you waiting for
your turn to speak
right the whole meditation practice that
you've been doing is now valuable in
this moment where you're focused
entirely on what they're saying to you
every distraction every screech of a car
tire outside everybody who's talking
around you you don't hear any of it you
only hear what they're saying to you are
entirely focused on what they're saying
to you and when you have your own
thoughts of advice you'd like to give or
things you want to tell them oh my god
me too that happened to me as well right
you say nope that's not important this
moment and you put it out of your head
and deal with it later
and at the end of that conversation your
friend will say thank you i feel heard
or thank you for being there for me or
thank you for holding space for me or
thank you for listening
and those are all
uh uh indications that congratulations
you've been present for another
and i think what gives our lives purpose
is not to wake up every morning to learn
meditation so that we can be present for
ourselves though that is valuable
what gives our lives purpose is to do
these things for another
there's nothing wrong with doing things
and enjoying the benefit of those things
yourself by all means
but the sense of the deep feeling sense
of purpose and meaning to one's life or
to one's work only
comes when those things are for another
and in my view primarily for another
where our benefit is secondary
you can't have equal there's no such
thing as equal because at one point one
of those things will have to be
sacrificed for the other and do you
sacrifice your spouse's love so that you
can stay in love or do you sacrifice
your comfort do you sacrifice as your
girlfriend boyfriend's spouses
comfort so that you can be better or do
you sacrifice your comfort so they can
feel better that's an obvious it's
obvious well it's the same here it's the
same analogy which is i choose to
sacrifice my my happiness my joy my
comfort my lamborghini
in this moment not forever but in this
moment
for you
for you my employee for you my friend
you know
um i will delay
so that you can have and that's where
the joy and love of business
relationships friendships come from
you know there's a great irony in all of
this which is to sacrifice for another
really is the most beautiful thing we
can ever do i mean that's kind of what
love is it's sacrificing for another
um and all of these things whether it's
learning to be a better communicator
learning mindfulness and meditation
being in shape if you can translate
those things in for another
all of those things start to have a
higher purpose
in the case of health doing it for
another you're saying that it would be
so that i can be here longer for my
family would be a much more joyful if i
had children for example sure
as long as it's real
it can't be generic you're right it
can't you just cut you can't just put it
out there just so it's fills the you
know
mad libs and you filled the gap yeah
yeah you know it's gotta you gotta
actually feel it that that ad actually
is the purpose i'll give you one then so
part i do think about this and i thought
about this last night when i was in the
gym was in part i think i work out
because i want to be healthy and in
shape for my for my girlfriend like i
want to be i want our relationship to be
good i want us to be able to be active
together i want her to be
attracted by me when i'm naked you know
like and i i had a debate with my team
as to like whether that's a noble reason
to work out
and should we have a feel and obligation
or whatever to be in shape for our our
other half
i think to be healthy for our her for
sure but you think the aesthetic stuff
is a bit i think it's fine i mean i
think the aesthetic stuff is about
confidence right which is i'm sure
she'll love you
even if you're chubby you know i'm sure
she'll love you even if you don't have a
sex pack you know
but if it makes you feel confident
then
it's like people have nose jobs you know
like somebody says you can't have a nose
job why are you well if it makes them
feel better about themselves then
how can we argue with it like if they if
they went from being really really
insecure and hiding their faces or bad
teeth and they never wanted to smile to
fixing their teeth and now they smile
all the time
like why why should we tell them they
can't now of course there's a line
getting addicted to plastic surgery is
something different and there is a line
but you know getting your teeth done or
getting a nose job to make yourself feel
better is
it's fine if it builds your comfort so
if it builds your confidence and then
and it's a and you're doing it in a
healthy way
you know
then you know it's like how can somebody
argue that you shouldn't be exercising
so it looks good now again there is a
line there are some people who actually
overdo it where if they stop exercising
they gain a tiny bit of weight they
actually spiral
there is a line where they're actually
not
building confidence they're actually
building in security
but some of these things don't have to
be big and lofty they can be
ridiculously small like so for example
for me
you know
i'm
very good at um disappointing myself
like i have no problem disappointing
myself right like i wake up in the
morning two hours before my alarm
and i'll say to myself you should work
out like
you're up super early you've got a busy
day and you just got an extra two hours
you could like use 30 minutes of that to
work out get out of bed i'm like
i'll sit in bed for two hours and just
like read the newspaper and play wordle
you know
and two hours will go by and i won't
work out
do i have any guilt
none i'm just like oh you're an idiot
simon right now if i'm meeting someone
at the gym
at 7 30 because we're gonna work out
i'll be there i won't let somebody down
i'm okay letting myself down but i won't
let somebody else down so for me
my purpose sometimes is very in the
moment like i'm doing this for them it's
like you know when i when i would run
you know one of the reasons i stayed in
good running shape is because when i ran
with my running buddy i never wanted to
ruin their run if they wanted to keep a
slightly higher pace i could keep it
so it doesn't always have to be big and
lofty sometimes it can be
in the moment
when you talked about awareness there
and the importance of trying to become
more aware about ourselves and one of
the things that made you aware was that
conversation with your partner yeah
where they said you don't listen you're
a shitty listener yeah um self-awareness
what i don't know if that's a real thing
but self-awareness um
seems to be the foundation of
personal growth right so becoming aware
about something in our lives and people
can read as i always say that people can
read as many books as they like but if
they're unable to read themselves
they'll never really learn a thing
for me and i i wrote that a couple of
years ago and i had a guy in my office
who read every single he was actually
one of the people that always came in
with your books right he read every
single book i've ever seen him he knew
every book
but he never changed yeah and and he and
there was things within him that he
wasn't self-aware about
that i believe were the reason why he
couldn't evolve even though he was
taking in so much information how does
warning go about what are the the key
ways we can go about increasing our
sense of self-awareness so that we can
grow and evolve
such a good question you know it's kind
of like people like that are a little
bit like yo-yo dieters you know
they do every diet but they're not
healthy people
i read every book but i'm not growing
and
you can't assess yourself
you know it's like can you i mean you
know this from work right which is at
some point somebody's gonna have to give
you feedback at some point you have to
give somebody else feedback like
self-assessment is a thing but it's not
the only thing it's a thing it's a data
point and i'm a huge believer in
self-assessment but you have to have
that
buttressed
with the
assessments of others because we are
blind very often we're social animals we
cannot do this thing called career or
life alone we're just not that smart
we're not that strong we're not that
aware we're just not that good
as social animals we actually need each
other to watch our backs and tell us
what's working and what's not working
and i think
for somebody who goes through life and
reads those books all the books you know
i get good on them i guess but are they
asking for help are they asking for
insight from others as opposed to just
reading it and agreeing with it and
thinking they're making the changes
i know my own personal journey and i try
and i do think of myself as
i i work hard to be self-aware and i
work hard to
self-evaluate but i i have seen in my
own life my ability to truly
demonstrate real
awareness
um and
move further down the the journey and
path called life
as opposed to staying stagnant
came when i let others help me you know
we we don't build trust by offering help
we build trust by asking for it
because it's a vulnerable thing to ask
for help
will you help me is a very very very
vulnerable statement can i help you
not so much an act of service
but the act of service really comes from
allowing somebody else to serve you
which it becomes this whole
weird twisted circular thing
you know it's like i mean i'll give you
a silly example
people who are bad at taking compliments
right
you're so smart no no no no no no right
we downplay it because we're embarrassed
by the compliment right but a compliment
is a gift
somebody's paying you a gift now if
somebody handed you a present you
wouldn't push it back
because it would be rude
right you would accept it whether you
like it or not or whether it makes you
comfortable or not you accept it with
gratitude and then you go evaluate it
later
no that's an ugly sweater you know
but you're still grateful for the
thought and the gift and the
compliment's the same and i think all of
these things the willingness to you know
to deny someone else the joy of giving
you the gift of the compliment and to
deny someone else
the intensity and joy of being there for
someone else again i think is selfish
never asking for help is selfish
asking for help is a great act of
service because you allow someone else
to have the joy of sacrifice and it goes
backwards and forwards it's not
one-sided and this is where i think
great relationships work which is we
take turns
and
sometimes it's really difficult when
both of us are in need at the same time
that gets really difficult good thing we
have friends
so
you know the height of kovid
um
i have a couple of my friends they're
sort of
remarkable high performing individuals
both of them
and
one of them called me out of the blue
and she went for a long walk she says
i'm
doing really badly
and i need to talk to you
and i don't want to talk to my husband
because he's doing really badly as well
and i fear that if i talk to him he
doesn't have the energy for me but i
know he want to be there for me which
will make it worse for him we're both
really struggling
can you have some time to talk
you know
and i mean
a the willingness to ask for help
b
the willingness to
understand that asking her husband for
help would made it even more difficult
for him it was just a very sophisticated
and beautiful moment and to this day we
became not only did we become closer for
it but her husband and i became closer
for it as well because i was there for
her when he knew he couldn't be
and this is why we have friends
like again we can't do this alone not
only are we social animals we're tribal
animals
you know it's more than a friend it
takes a community
um
and i think one of the you know we're
always talking about what we're eating
and we're talking about what we're you
know what
you know what
supplement we're taking or we're always
talking about those kinds of things or
what book we're reading
but we we don't do enough talking about
how we are nursing
[Music]
our close personal relationships how
we're taking care of those closest to us
and making sure that the tribe is strong
um the crew is taken care of you know
um and i think there's a lot more work
that we can do in that arena
is there practical things that you do
with colleagues
partners friends to create that culture
of
seeking feedback being open being truly
vulnerable you know some people say oh
we'll have
we'll sit down with our diary and we'll
write we'll do this exercise or you
might have seen in organizations where
they do like 360 feedback things is
there is there practical things we can
do to
create a culture of seeking out that
feedback and creating a safe space well
the simple answer is of course um
the there's no such thing as a single
silver bullet it's a combination of
things it's like what's the one thing i
can do to happy have a happy
relationship well i can't i can tell you
a important thing but i can't tell you
the important thing so it's the same
um and everybody's a little different
you know and each culture is a little
different so there's there's not even a
set list i can give but there's some
things that people can choose from you
know one thing is one of the ways we
create space is how we react right if
someone gives you feedback and you deny
it
well that's a problem
if somebody gives you hard feedback and
you thank them for it it's a very
different
environment it creates so i i i'll give
you two
uh examples one
a lesson the other one a practical
example that someone can use
so i had the opportunity to visit the
army rangers uh ranger school in
particular and i where they make
they make army rangers and one of the
troubles they had a a bunch of years ago
was they had these folks that they
called spotlight rangers
which was they were really good at their
job like they were brilliant at all the
tasks that were set to them strong
their the teachers the instructors loved
them they stood out they were great they
were motivated
but as soon as the spotlight was turned
off when the instructor wasn't there and
they were back in barracks they were
[ __ ]
and the only person who the only people
who knew were there were their friends
and colleagues because the spotlight was
turned off
and so the army rangers implemented a
system of peer review
in order to identify spotlight rangers
and in now
by the way they started this 40 years
ago which i find incredibly advanced
but to advance through ranger school you
need to pass three tests you need your
instructor to say yep you're ready to go
to the next level you need to physically
actually perform all the tasks required
of you and you need to pass your peer
review
um
and if you fail any one of those three
you don't make it to the next level
interesting and so that becomes
an equally weighted component of
advancement in the army rangers which is
what kind of team player are you
which i love
so
we implemented a system of 360 review
um
which was sort of a bit of an
amalgamation of things we'd taken from
other groups and made our own
where what we
the way it works is um
you take the group of people you have
regular interaction with and
you
um
[Music]
fill out
uh your top three
weaknesses
or the places you believe you need to
grow the most
with a specific example for each so top
three specific
weaknesses or places you need to grow
the most and then
top three specific strengths
or the places you believe
three examples of the places you believe
you've grown the most they have to be
specific
not like oh i'm a much better time
keeper now no that
got to give some specific examples
they're collated and distributed amongst
the team
and then you come together as a group
and
you take turns
reading them
so first you read your own
weaknesses
and then the group has the opportunity
to add to that list
and here's the best part we give a
little speech before the whole exercise
starts that the people who are going to
give you this feedback
really don't want to
it's really uncomfortable for them
it's going to be
uh
they would just rather not do this
exercise at all
but they're going to do it because they
want to see you and help you grow
and so what they're giving you is a gift
and so you have to receive it as a gift
which means you say thank you
you don't have to agree with it
if you don't agree with it say thank you
and just dismiss it it's fine but if it
has an emotional impact if it makes you
angry
or frustrated
it's probably true
right
and we go around the room and somebody
tell every people can add to this list
of these weaknesses in any way that
there's no format they can do it in any
way they want and you sit there and you
look them in the eye and you generally
say thank you you're not allowed to say
a word except thank you
then you do your strengths and you read
your threat strengths and anyone can add
to the list and just as you discovered
you have blind spots you didn't know you
have you discovered that you have
strengths that you didn't know you had
that you're having a positive impact in
the lives of others that you didn't know
you were
and it's a magical experience there's
usually tears at some point
because it's powerful and it's a safe
environment i wouldn't recommend an
organization start there i would
recommend you build towards that because
you're going to put very senior people
and very junior people in the same room
and they're going to have very blunt
conversations with each other and it's
it's real
right it's not a place to start but it
is a place to get to i mean there are
variations for it that one takes a lot
of time you know we've we've very we
varied as where everybody's responsible
to do it and you can you have two people
assigned and you can choose one or two
people to join and you just have a
smaller a smaller group when you want to
do it you know and it's just for you so
the others don't do it in that moment
it's it's a little more efficient to do
it that way um but there's no right or
wrong way i really love that idea of the
promotion being contingent on not just
the your manager
or you're the ceo
believing that you are x y and z but
getting peer reviewed by the colleagues
around you because one of the things i
noticed in my company we had and when i
left there was about 700 people but
i would have i would hear reports about
a particular team member
and the reports i would get back about
their character and their conduct never
matched the way they treated me
so they would always treat me of course
amazingly right of course right and then
i'd hear that they treated this person
like this and they did this and i'd go
really and they'd go yeah really
they were always so nice to me and
obviously on that basis i would have
promoted that individual and thought
they were great so that's definitely
something i'll implement that's called a
tree of monkeys by the way it's called
the tree of monkeys which is um
all the people at the top looking down
see only smiles but all the people at
the bottom looking up see on the air
oh [ __ ] yeah that makes perfect sense
and again you there's you don't have to
do you don't have to i mean there's
again there's different cultures can
accept different you know there's no
right or wrong here
you know and some cultures may want to
implement a peer review that gets
included in a promotion package but it
doesn't have to be that
good leadership helps there as well
which is every senior person knows that
they don't get the truth
i mean even if your people are wonderful
and fantastic
people want to tell you the right answer
not because they're trying to lie to you
but they want to please you like you you
knew the more senior you got it was
harder and harder to get the truth and
every senior leader knows that it's hard
to get the truth every great senior
leader also has spies
somebody that maybe you started you were
friends with that people don't know
you're friends with or you came up
through the ranks of the organization
together but your career went a little
further a little quicker
you know that you have these trusted
relationships that you can just get a
little inside scoop as to what's really
going on
um
also this is the hardest one
is or at least it's a hard one learning
to replace
judgment with curiosity
so somebody comes to you and says
that person is a problem
and all of a sudden we create a
narrative based on the story that they
tell us that they are a problem that
person's stupid that person's lazy
whatever it is now they're labeled as
lazy now we treat them as lazy now
everything that they do or don't do
because they're lazy
right
um but as a good leader we want to we
can take those reports
we can take that hearsay
we can take those direct stories that
people have and we can say thank you i
appreciate that i'll look into it i'm
going to find out more
and you go on a little journey to
discover what's really happening
it absolutely may be
that they're lazy that could 100 be it
or maybe they're distracted for a reason
or maybe they're having trouble at home
or maybe we've given them a job that
they're ill qualified for or maybe
they're having a personality conflict
with somebody that they work with like
the list goes on and on and on and on
and the good leader
is finding that out and by the way by
leader i don't mean the senior person i
mean any person in the organization
um
to replace that judgment with curiosity
and i think that's what creates those
environments but the reality is is with
rank you do set the tone
so for example um no lying that seems
like a pretty simple one inside a
company we don't tell lies okay phone
rings
your assistant picks up
uh
they put the person on hold and they
call out to you
uh
david's on the phone
and you go tell him i'm not here
you've just sanctioned a lie
you've just sanctioned a lie
right and that little lie then now that
person who was told to lie
approvingly now they can tell a lie
right because it came from the boss and
all of a sudden you find out you have an
organization that tells lies all over
the place and some of those lies grow
it happened to me once where
um
i had a very very senior phone call with
the top leaders of a really big
organization
like and i forgot
i just didn't show up on the call i just
i have no no excuse i just
i forgot to check my calendar and
i forgot
and
my assistant at the time of course
wanted to protect my reputation
and she wrote to them and said terribly
sorry simon had another meeting that ran
long
and i took her aside and it was the
hardest feedback i had to give because
she did it with such good intention i
said i am so grateful i'm so grateful
that you're protecting me and you're
protecting my reputation
and i want you to do that
but you have to do that without lying
we cannot lie you can say i'm sorry he's
late i'm sorry he missed the call
but you cannot say
it's because he was in another meeting
because that's not true
and so you it's this you know i mean
i'll challenge you you try this right
let's look at the time right now right
it's it's noon okay it's noon on i don't
know what day it is monday right
you and your entire crew here's the
challenge for all of you okay
you may not tell a single lie
for the next 48 hours i mean
nothing
and you'll be amazed how difficult it is
you'll be amazed how many little white
lies we tell
like
the waiter comes over
and five minutes before you're saying oh
this food is so salty
and the way it comes to goes how is
everything you go it's fine everything's
fine yeah thank you it's fine that is a
lie
right now you don't have to be mean
there's nothing that says truth has to
be brutal it just has to be true
try for the next 48 hours and see how
hard it is not to tell a single lie
everyone's going to be walking around
asking each other what they think of
each other
now simon says you've got to be honest
right but there's ways of doing it right
like so
um do these genes make me look fat
i like the other genes much better
they're way more flattering
right you don't have to hurt people
also timing
right
so a true story so i went to see a
friend's
play
and uh
i i could not wait for this thing to end
it was so bad
and i went out you know
to say hi to her after the performance
and she came out
she was still in costume and makeup
and she knows i'm an honest broker
she cares about what i she knows i'll
always tell her the truth and these
kinds of things and she says to me what
did you think
now
now is not the time and place she's
pumped up full of adrenaline
and
now is not the time for me to give her a
critical evaluation of of this god-awful
performance
and so
i sidestepped the question but said
something true i said ah it was such a
treat to be here to see you do your
thing
you know i've been wanting to see you on
a stage forever and it was so much fun
to see you on the stage all of that was
true
the next day when the adrenaline had
come down and
i called her up and said can i tell you
what i thought about the play she goes
yeah of course and i told her critically
piece by piece what i thought about it
and how bad it was we had a perfectly
rational conversation about it didn't
hurt her feelings the day before it
would have really hurt her feelings so
not everything has to be we mistake
being honest with being honest now
no i can't lie
and i have to answer the question
but it can answer it tomorrow when the
conditions are better
for that message to be received what is
so insidious or what is so harmful what
is the long-term negative impact of
creating that culture of lying within
teams and within ourselves
well there's a there's this there's this
psychological uh
phenomenon i guess called ethical fading
which can
grip an organization's culture
where
people within that culture become
capable of making highly highly
unethical decisions believing they were
well within their own ethical frameworks
right
so extreme examples
are things like pharmaceutical companies
who have a patent on an essential drug
and in order to meet or beat some
financial projection they raise the
price of that essential drug 100 500
1000
1500
totally legal there's nothing illegal
about that
really unethical
right
and
in organizations that suffer ethical
fading it almost always if not always
starts from the top it's usually a
leadership problem
it comes from excessive amounts of
pressure to hit certain short-term goals
to the point where
doing it ethically becomes more and more
difficult
and so what creates ethical fading is a
series of things one of those things is
we we rationalize
right we look for ways to distance
ourselves from the impact of our
decisions we say things like it's what
you got to do to get ahead
it's what my boss wants
um everyone's doing it
it's the system i don't have a choice
right
um and there are ways we can
disassociate our responsibility right so
rationalizing is a big part of it
another part is the old slippery slope
you did it once you did it a little bit
it worked we raised the price 10 nobody
even noticed great do it again do 20
this time try 100
and it just keeps going and going and
going and going before you have
full-blown ethical fading
and
some of the things are excessive use of
euphemisms again we're using language to
disassociate ourselves from the impact
of our decisions so for example you know
we in the united states would never
torture but enhanced interrogation that
sounds very appealing
right or companies would never spy on
their customers but data mining yeah i
know we're really into that
right
um
we're just using different language to
mask the insidiousness of our real
decisions like everybody talks about
managing externalities
but we don't talk about the damage we're
doing to the people and cultures
environments of the places where our
offices and factories are located why
don't you have that conversation
and so when you have enough of those
things
ethical fading shows up where you now
have
real issues and in the extreme you have
massive scandals sometimes it leads to
illegal activity but usually it's just
unethical scandals
and when those things happen management
is dragged out and they talk to the
newspaper to the law and they always say
the same thing which is we broke no laws
everything we do is legal no we don't
have an issue with the law we have an
issue with your ethics
but when you don't have when it's not
full-blown it just becomes an incredibly
uncomfortable and a horrible place to
work
that increases stress to the point where
you'll do damage to your own health and
you'll do damage to the way you treat
your family because when you're into
that kind of stress to violate your own
ethics
at work um you're gonna come home you're
gonna take it out in your your spouse
and your kids you're gonna kick the dog
um you're not gonna be motivated to do
much except sit and sit on the couch and
watch tv
you know
so it has it's had some pretty insidious
uh impact in the lives of human beings i
was thinking of it as well in terms of
romantic relationships
one little white lie becomes another
little white lie and then a couple of
you know a year passes and you're so
unaligned and so far from your truth
that you're resentful that you're having
to keep up with this
set of lies i mean we've talked about it
with a guest on this podcast before one
of the mistakes i made in my
relationship at the start was i would
say yes to things that i didn't like
doing yeah so i created this culture and
there's also this like expectation when
my partner thought i loved doing
x activity at six a.m in the morning
because i'd always said yes and i'd
always pretended to like it now i have
to live out that life of something i do
not enjoy doing because i lied at the
start
and the journey back is not always so
easy when you've
i i i've made the same mistake on the
other side which is
after i broke up with someone when we
maintained a friendship
and i started dating somebody or at
least started dating
but i didn't want to hurt the feelings
of this person i still care about that
we broke up you know a couple months
before
um and so if i would avoid the
conversation but if she said are you
dating anybody i'd say no not really
and it's not because i wanted a lies
because i don't want to hurt her like
the intention of course is positive
but what i learned later is all of those
little lies
meant that
she was holding out hope that wasn't
there and by the way it's been done to
me as well i'm holding out hope that's
not there because someone didn't want to
hurt my feelings and i would rather just
have the uncomfortable conversation
are you dating somebody you are
okay well that hurts but i can heal
i can move on
and you know again
this young
generation because of all the reasons
we've talked about
and more
seems to exhibit
the traits of being very conflict
avoidant
very uncomfortable with uncomfortable
that has some
impact that are
sometimes
funny
quote unquote but always
tend to make somebody feel more lonely
so for example and i've seen this happen
i've heard about these stories so many
times
a young employee
who
may feel they're in line for a raise
but it's so uncomfortable to go to their
boss
and ask for a raise
that they just quit
that they would rather quit and have an
uncomfortable conversation
and then
sometimes
it is followed by a
an angry email that says i'm undervalued
you don't appreciate me you underpay me
you know
and and i've i've heard it happen so
many times where
the leadership is like
what we would have happily
like i'm sorry we were either planning
on giving you a raise we'd happen to
give you a raise you know and
it's really uncomfortable to walk in
your boss's office and be like hey i'm
working really hard can i have a raise
please now the time you do get to quit
is when you've had this conversation
four five six times and you've seen
nothing and had no feedback and had no
impact then absolutely you quit and
absolutely you say you undervalue me you
under appreciate we've under under
appreciate me we've had this
conversation five or six times then it's
their fault
because they had all the information
but again it's really funny how many
young kids would were they they would
rather quit than have a difficult
conversation or they'd rather break up
than have a difficult conversation or
worse they'd rather ghost someone than
break up with them
because it's really uncomfortable to
have a fight and a breakup
and call each other names
it's much easier to just turn off all
the social media un unfollow everywhere
i know we've been dating for six months
but i'm just going to now ignore every
text ignore all your calls and think
about it from the we talk about service
think about the service or disservice we
do the other person for their their
point of view
it's like you got in a car accident it's
like you were just killed it's like you
just disappeared off the planet that is
trauma
because you're uncomfortable to have an
uncomfortable conversation you would do
that to someone another person so
service goes both ways which is i will
make myself
uncomfortable and have a difficult
conversation even if i bumble it and
screw it up and it ends up being a
screaming match
because that is a better option
than traumatizing a person where they
have to believe that i've first of all
that i've died because they can't get
hold of me in the panic and then when
they realize i'm alive because they see
me on instagram
that now i've destroyed their
self-confidence
how dare somebody do that to another
human being because you're just a little
uncomfortable of having an uncomfortable
conversation where we can help
is we can teach people how to have
uncomfortable conversations that is a
skill set
we don't teach leaders how to have
uncomfortable conversations we don't
teach students how to have uncomfortable
conversations we don't teach you know we
can teach these things all over the
place
and i think it's i think it's a big
gaping hole in curriculum we teach you
know maths and we teach english but we
don't teach social interaction we don't
teach listening we don't we don't teach
how to have uncomfortable conversations
we don't teach how to give and receive
feedback
you know now you tell me which is going
to be more valuable for the rest of your
life how to have a difficult
conversation or trigonometry
yeah
and shouldn't we be you know isn't this
shouldn't we be preparing people for
life
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast as the seasons
have begun to change so has my diet and
um right now i'm going to be completely
honest with you i'm starting to think a
lot about
slimming down a little bit because over
the last couple of probably the last
four or five months my diet has been
pretty bad um and it started to show a
little bit really over the last two
months i go to the gym about 80 percent
of the time so i track it with 10 of my
friends in a whatsapp group and this
tracker online that we all use together
we call it fitness blockchain and i'm
currently at 81
so 81 of the days i've done a workout in
the last 150 days right so i'm going to
the gym about six times a week
that's been a little bit impacted by the
derivative live tour but i'm trying to
stick to it
and so one of the things i'm doing now
to reduce my calorie intake and trying
to get back to being nutritionally
complete and all i eat is i'm having the
heel protein shake thank you hill for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is the one
on that point of that new generation in
the workplace and how they're they're
exhibiting traits of being a little bit
more cowardly
in terms of having those difficult
conversations you made a video about
millennials in the workplace that did
probably hundreds of millions of views
yeah i remember seeing it on facebook
maybe five years ago and it i think it
had 50 million views on that one video
but across youtube it's got tens of
millions of views on many many different
videos
but i'm thinking now about that new
generation that you've described that
younger generation that gen's their
generation that are emerging into the
like postcovid world
what is the workplace for them what how
do i as a leader make sure that if i'm
hiring gen z and i've got a couple even
in this room that work in my company
what have we got to know about them and
do to make sure that they thrive stay
motivated and achieve their goals
this is my own bias
i don't like the conversation
of
strengths and weaknesses
um you know it's the famous question you
know in an interview what's your biggest
weakness well i'm a perfectionist you
know
uh
i don't like the conversations of
strengths and weaknesses because
strengths often have liability
i'm really confident okay in the wrong
context you're arrogant
right
but weaknesses also have
silver linings so for me i'm chronically
disorganized i'm terrible right every
system app
works for like a week and then i'm back
to being disorganized
is that a good thing or a bad thing now
for years i used to beat myself up for
it and say it's a bad thing it's a
terrible weakness but the reality is
it's context so i was as a young
entrepreneur i was at this networking
event
and i met this guy who's like really
impressed with what i had to say with my
pitch and he's like simon we have to do
work together here's my business card
call me let's do this
and i lost the business card basically
as soon as he gave it to me so anybody
who was organized would be sending a
text from the taxi or at least sending
an email the next day not yahoo over
here i lost the business card there was
no way for me to find out what this
important piece of business would have
led to because i lost the card
two weeks later i found the business
card at the bottom of a briefcase
so i emailed him and said hey remember
we met two weeks ago you know i'd love
to reconnect and see if we can work
together still he wanted to work with me
more because he thought i was busy
so strength or weakness the answer is it
depends now in general yes it is a
weakness it's a liability and it causes
me great stress but not always is the
point and so yes it's important for us
to understand our characteristics
that we exhibit of which some of them in
the con in certain contexts are huge
strengths and some of the exact same
characteristics in the wrong context are
huge weaknesses
right so it's very it's we have to be
very careful when we label people or
generations as being strong or weak
because the answer is it depends
okay so that's the preface so we talk
about this young generation
the the gen z generation they exhibit
many of the same characteristics as the
previous generation but they're quite
different in the sense that they're very
activist right so for example in the
1950s and 60s people hated their jobs
back then too they just went to work
every day and just suffered in silence
you know by the time you get to the 80s
and 90s people hated their jobs but then
they'd at least start talking around
about it around the office saying you
know this this job kind of sucks a
little bit you know and then by the time
you get sort of the 2000s people start
speaking up to their bosses saying i
think we should make it better to work
here you know and now you in this young
generation and they're just like
they're like standing up and quitting
and like and i love it right and and and
they organize they're much more you know
the previous generation would like
hashtag tweet my discontent as i'm
sitting in my uber on my way to brunch
you know but this young generation gets
out and organizes and comes together
plus or minus it depends sometimes it's
a huge strength the fact that they have
that kind of energy but sometimes as
we've talked about as well they also
have the energy to quit instead of
having an uncomfortable conversation so
strength or weakness it depends and so i
think the way we have to approach all of
these things is with empathy which is
instead of
uh
deciding if it's a strength or weakness
to try and understand where it comes
from because i can say this generation
is irresponsible and will quit before
they ask for a a raise
or i can say
why is it that they're quitting before
they get a when they just need a raise
what's mis what's what's what happened
between a and b and that thought in
those two actions you know and i'm like
oh they just missed the skill set oh we
can totally figure that one out that
one's an easy fix so i'm not labeling a
whole person or a whole generation i'm
not rather recognizing that there's gaps
of
skills which we all have so when you ask
me about any of the generations
and they all have strengths they all
have liabilities
and depending on the time frame and the
context sometimes sometimes those
strengths also
become old-fashioned
no longer necessary you know they can
still cause frustration they can still
cause confusion
you know we're still looking through
them at our through our own prisms of
our own generation i've definitely
caught myself doing it you know i do do
it my goodness we never did that when we
were kids you know when i was their age
i'm actually saying that now
but um i think the the
the trial
the the the test
is the practice of empathy which is
another skill that we can teach that's
missing how is this the coveted
experiment on the workforce and the
workplace
so how do like business leaders or
business owners need to adjust in order
to
make sure we don't
lose people and become an
un
compelling unattractive place to work in
this post-coveted era
and also on the point you talked about
earlier about the importance of like
we're social animals we need that social
connection and we're being kind of we're
optimizing that out of our lives it
feels to me like this remote working
thing has has exacerbated the
issue because we're you know for young
people you know i think that the office
is one of the few institutions we have
left where we are in person we no longer
get dating we do that on apps that's
right food we don't go to restaurants
anymore we just order ubereats and our
work they're telling us is going to be
done from zoom i'm like what do we have
left they're lonely
we're going to be lonely
and it's not a coincidence that we see
rising rates of depression anxiety
suicide you know especially in younger
generations so
you know
it's not causal but it's there's
definitely correlation
you know it reminds me of when um
and i'm old enough for this some of your
listeners are not but i remember when
the internet showed up
and e-commerce started
and i remember some of the people who
are really into the tech
running around thinking this is the
death of bricks and mortars they will
never be stores again
and now amazon opens stores and
rent the runway open stores and
turns out it's
the extremes are not great places you
know it's not the death it's live
alongside they become different animals
they become different reasons we go to
shops not to get the best deal
you go to you go to you go to websites
to get the best deal
you go to shops because it's fun
you go to shops to try stuff on you go
to shops because it's an activity
because we our hunter gatherer instincts
we like foraging and looking for things
it's entertainment
we enjoy the service aspect you know
it's with our friends sometimes it's not
about the shops at all it's just a place
something to do with our friends it
plays a different role
and the smart retailers know that
and so when we talk about work it's the
same
it's the death of the corporate
headquarters the death of the office i'm
like
is it though
you know
the reality is
this is going to be somewhere in the
middle and i think one thing with all
the predictions about what the future of
work looks like i think one thing we can
be absolutely sure of is there'll be
more flexibility
where
you know where it used to be hey boss
can i take off next friday can i work
from home next friday i have to stay
home for whatever right
becomes emailing in the morning saying
i'm working from home today and
everybody's just fine with it
you know
introverts liking work working from home
extroverts like working at the office
but at the same time sometimes
extroverts should stay home because
they can get more work done and
sometimes introverts need to come to the
office because they need to connect and
and and we want you to be a part of the
culture and so
i don't think you know making any
predictions about what it will look like
i think is a little foolish at this time
we know it'll be
some sort of amalgamation we know it'll
be more flexible and probably every
office will be slightly different and
it'll fit whatever their culture is
and i think the office environment will
become one of the selling selling things
which is if somebody really hates this
rfis environment they'll find another
company where they like the office
environment
but i think what's really interesting
about the great resignation what's being
talked about less
and the great resignation is sort of the
reasons for it some people talk about
the government checks that we've gotten
that runs out so that's not the main
reason for it
people talk about uh how people are
quitting to follow their dreams you know
i've always wanted to be an actor or a
writer great and that is definitely a
percentage and i
and i love that but that's not
those numbers aren't big enough
i think
what i think is more interesting
is that the great resignation is an
indictment
on decades
of substandard corporate culture and
poor leadership
where
and because it's a big deal that we're
seeing people especially at
um front line level jobs
which um
where leadership used to say of them
they should just be happy to have a job
right
um
that
those people are quitting without new
jobs necessarily is a big deal
and they're definitely not all just
following their dreams
i think it is because in the past you
know when you ask those people how's
work and they'd be like it's fine
is it good no it's it's fine it's a job
it's fine
well why didn't you quit because the
unknown was way scarier than fine
and so they may do with fine and
leadership took advantage a lot of
corporate managers took advantage of the
fact that they could get away with fine
we could do the minimum because they're
not going to leave
they're lucky to have a job and what are
they going to go out there and the the
great unknown fine is fine
and then covet happened
and a lot of people were laid off a lot
of people lost their jobs
a lot of people were furloughed
some people kept their jobs but just
lived in fear
and we all kind of made it out okay
we ate
we had food
you know
most people
made it okay
even if it was difficult they made it
through and so all of a sudden the great
unknown a lot less scary
and so when you're offering me fine i
choose unknown
that's a better option
in fact not only do i choose unknown i'm
going to wait until you fix fine and i
don't think enough companies are
recognizing
that the great resignation is an
indictment that the great resignation is
a
wag of the finger that you have been
getting away with substandard culture
and poor leadership for too long
and you better fix your stuff
and i think the companies that will have
the huge advantages is not the combat
the companies that get the balance of
in-person or or or
or online work
right i don't think that's what makes it
i think the companies that get the huge
advantage moving forward are the ones
that teach leadership to their leaders
that teach these human skills that we've
been talking about that create a
corporate environment and a corporate
culture that i want to go to every day
and i actually form good strong bonds
with my new tribe with the people i go
to work with and i'm willing to
sacrifice and not get everything exactly
how i want it because i'd rather be here
and serve these wonderful group of
people those are the companies that will
have the huge advantage of the next
decades or two one of the things that i
saw in that postcode period was in my
company in particular was
one of the things that
i believe and from our
our research at the time i'm no longer
with this company so i can kind of talk
about it um with a bit more honesty
in our in our questionnaires we would
see that a lot of the reason why people
love to come and work there was because
of the
the company culture right we're done
we've gone to extreme lengths we had
like five people that were just in
charge of happiness called the happiness
team
we paid for everyone's mental health
therapy it was a very it was the it was
in terms of flexibility what the world
is like now or you can decide for
yourself when you work and then when
covert came around we were like known
for that in the uk like the bbc demo
pieces this the best place to work when
covert came around it smashed our usp
because it and this is why i almost
viewed it as a leveler because now
everyone was working from their laptop
at home in their box of shorts so now
what i think i saw was our employees
were going to some degree
i can work at home in my box of shorts
for this company or i can work home in
my box of shorts for this company where
they'll pay me double yeah
and and that shift was and it was
terrifying for us because that's when we
started to see people leaving because
they would go oh well this company will
give me 30 more and i'm still going to
be doing my to-do list at home on my own
so why not move now
is there truth to that in your view yeah
of course because you mistook
um trappings for culture
right right now those things are good
let's not diminish the value of those
things
but this this is a beautiful full circle
we're going in from the very beginning
of our conversation which is to what end
to what end like what are we doing this
in service too what's the bigger thing
that was missing and that was missing
100 and that's that's
that's where cultures become magic
they're fun
like you know the number of companies
you and i have both visited that have
you know flat screens everywhere amazing
design freeze free lunch
you know
we had a slide yeah yeah you have a
slide like cool you know now is somebody
going to turn down a better paying job
to keep that no
you know
but if you give them the opportunity to
contribute to something bigger
themselves
would they turn down a better paying job
now
yes
right and so i think
it's probably driven by the whole
dot-com tech culture
um
but it's it's you know because tech
companies largely are that sort of
ridiculous
bright color slides in every office you
know which is fun don't get me wrong
it's fun
um but that that's not that's not
cause
that's not purpose
uh and great cultures are are are
organized to advance something bigger
than themselves they're not just fun
places to work you know the thing i
think we did wrong is i think we asked
people what they wanted yeah so they
said things like
a bar yeah a basketball hoop whereas
as you've as you're clearly alluding to
here you can't ask people for culture
like in that regard you can't ask people
for to all
name the collective cause because
they'll all say different things correct
you have to you have to offer them a
cause to join yeah that's one of the
reasons they join the companies because
they believe in the cause
not just because it's a a job i want to
do
um you know henry ford famously said if
i asked people what they wanted they
would have said a faster horse
you know this is where
folks like steve jobs who's given
too much credit for being able to
predict what people want is totally not
true
it's he had a cause and he simply made
products that brought that cause to life
which is
to give people
the power
to stand up to big brother
that's it
and we develop technology to empower
individuals
that's it
you know
and so those who came to work there
they recognized that they were a part of
a revolution the computer revolution
they constantly talked about it as the
revolution then they invented itunes
which more than the ipod revolutionized
the music industry turned it from an
album culture to a song culture
let us make music portable
you know um and that was the music they
referred to as the music revolution
um
and
and you carried a banner you know and
you sacrificed for it was it a great
place to work it was a hard place to
work
but it was worth it and that's the
question are the sacrifices worth it and
sometimes we
we
hide
the pain or the difficulties or the
strains or the stresses with all the
silly fun stuff which is a salve let's
be honest i mean it does work to some
degree
but not all
stress is bad you know you know i i i
joke
you know
often
you know when we work hard for something
we love it's called passion
we work hard for something we don't love
it's called stress now in both cases
you're working hard you know what's the
difference what's the difference between
you know
doing something you love and you work
late hours and you sacrifice your
relationships and you sacrifice your
family but you look at and say
ah it was hard but it was worth it
you know versus losing all those things
and all you do is get a lamborghini at
the end you know it's like was it worth
it i'm like ah not so sure i'd do that
again
you know
um
and so i think that's what that's what
purpose and cause provide us is they
give us a reason for the sacrifice
that's what love gives us because it's
the reason for the sacrifice that's what
children do they give us the reason for
the sacrifice your life will profoundly
change when you have a child is it worth
it yes
is it easy no every person i've ever
talked to who has children
say it's the most difficult thing
they've ever done
and if you ask them if it's worth it
they will say yes
that doesn't go together
you
know when i think about even this
podcast and setting
purposeful goals for what we're doing
here
we definitely fell in the trap of being
like i think a lot of people do you get
consumed in the charts oh my god we're
number one
right for now for now yeah and then you
scratch your head and go well then what
what next what's sake what's a more
worthy more purposeful goal for us to
have as a team when we're building
something like this podcast because it's
so easy to get you know caught up in
we've been born in the charts and sure
and that does drive you to some extent
yeah it seems to be a a reason whether
it's a a vapid one or whatever
but what is a better
more worthy purposeful goal to set
okay so let's take a step back uh-oh
can you interrogate me no
what was the reason you did episode one
um
plentiful i'm gonna give you all of them
i'm very honest as well
thought podcasting as a medium would be
a big opportunity i thought that was
would be a really effective medium of
communication when that's growing
opportunity for what to
grow my personal brand okay i'm going to
give you all of the reasons even the
selfish ones okay
number two
i
find a thrill and deeply compelling and
liberating for others to talk about
things and be honest in a way that most
people aren't usually honest so in the
first episode i talk about things like
masturbation
and mental health problems as a ceo
difficulties with my family all of those
things i find it liberating for myself
but i know for others that listen to it
when especially when we got um started
to get the feedback it was equally
liberating for them and then when you so
episode one is a little episode one was
more of an experiment but it's okay so
episode yeah episode two whatever then
it was the feedback so i was doing a lot
of other things that were doing bigger
views my facebook videos would get 10
million each 10 million views each but
the feedback i was getting from the
thousand people that were listening to
this was deep it was profound and it was
intense and it said things like they
said things like
i can relate to that um that's really
helped me solve this problem i've had
you've made me a big one we get is
you've made me feel like i'm not alone
and then going if i go to the last like
you know if i go to more recent times i
quit when i left my job and i was now no
longer needed to do anything for money
anymore in my life
when i took stock of because there was
about a six month or one year gap in
this podcast which is when i was leaving
my job
and i took stock of my life and thought
about the things i want to do for the
rest of my life and this was one of the
things that seemed to touch all bases it
was
enjoyable for myself i get to sit and
learn from people like yourself it feels
like as you said it's like a service to
others a really profound one probably
the most the great service i feel like i
can do to the external world
and it's it's money generating but to be
honest if it makes a profit i just spend
it on a podcast
so uh
yeah and that's where that's kind of my
my thesis so okay so let's back up a
second yeah i'm just taking on your own
words i'm not adding anything here
would you rather do this to be number
one
to grow your own brand
or would you rather grow this would you
rather do this to tell the truth
so it helps others tell the truth to
themselves and to others
number two
obviously yeah and so your podcast
absolutely has purpose
and so when you start recognizing that
we do this
we do this to tell the truth so that
others can be honest with themselves and
others
in a way that they struggle to find
anywhere else
and if we're number one for a period of
time amazing
but if we're number two we'll still do
it with number four we'll still do it
everyone know the term will still do it
because there's a reason to do this
that's bigger
now if
the numbers are steadily declining and
no one's listening
then maybe we're doing something wrong
to spread our message maybe we've gone
off base maybe we're maybe we're not
telling the truth like we used to we
need to reevaluate if we're still
fulfilling our purpose or maybe the
manner or medium that we're using is no
longer relevant
so you know because things change in
time too
so that's why the metrics do matter
but the absolute of the metrics don't
matter the trend of the metrics matter
and so you do have purpose for this and
that
means you have to practice that kind of
truth telling with your team who work on
this podcast because you have to live
when the microphone is off the same way
you live when the microphone is on
and
that starts to have a profound impact on
you and your team so if that becomes the
purpose rather than being number one
maybe it gives people a reason to stick
around here
because
they believe in it
it's benefited them is there a role for
those arbitrary goals
is that
are they useful to say we want to be
number one in the united states is that
a useful goal to set ourselves um
alongside the sense of purpose can they
coexist
they can co-exist as long as you're
as long as you recognize the reason
right because if you become too obsessed
with the goal
at the sacrifice of the cause like there
is a hierarchy the cause comes first
because the goal comes first
you can look i know authors
who and i'm sure you know i'm sure
there's ways to do it in podcast as well
but like i know authors who are number
one amazon bestsellers well that's
because you can game the you can game
the algorithm you just have all your
friends buy a book on the same hour
because it's calculated hourly and
congratulations you can't be
a number one amazon bestseller with the
worst book in the world it exists you
can do it i've seen it
there are companies that
you can buy
a new york times bestseller
like they know how to game the new york
times algorithm and they buy books
across the country basically you buy the
books and they buy them on your behalf
so and if
and i've had an opportunity to look at
the publishers
like look at the publishers computers
where you can see any book we can track
any book book sales and they've showed
me they showed me how the trend works
that you can tell who game the system
and there are some very famous authors
that i will not mention on this podcast
who i know for a fact because i looked
at the the
that they brag about how they're new
york times best sellers well it's
because they paid for it they bought all
those books themselves right you can
game all these systems and if you're too
obsessed
with the number because you think the
number is what gives you credibility
then it goes back to ethical fading
again then the pressure becomes
overwhelming and you start doing things
that have nothing to do with the podcast
or the cause and only have to do with
advancing the number so you can go
around telling people you got the number
right
great good for you you know and
you know i don't
it's not how i choose to build my
business or live my life you know
but
i think what's more fun is to be
surprised
which is is it okay to be driven to be
number one as long as you're doing it
second and the pud and the and the cause
comes first sure if that's your thing
um
but just be prepared to answer what what
next
you know because you you can't be number
one forever i love it when companies say
i'm number one or i've got the number
one podcast and you heard i always say
for now
for now like that stuff doesn't last
even if it's 10 years it still won't
last
right
quick one we bring in eight people a
month to watch these conversations live
here in the studio when we're here in
the uk and when we're in la if you want
to be one of those people all you've got
to do is hit subscribe
what are you working on at the moment
simon because you're
you're known for writing amazing books
and delivering amazing content what are
you working on what's what's compelling
you at the moment what's your why
well my why is to inspire people to do
the things that inspire them so to each
of those so that each of us can change
our world for the better that is the the
foundation of everything that i do and
and that's the test
through which i
run everything that i will do like does
this inspire people to affect some sort
of change or perspective
um
why does that matter to you
it's not that it matters to me it's
that's who i am
it's like that's core to my being like
you're why is courtier being my wise
court of my being that's my personality
it's what wakes me up every day it's
what fulfills me it's what fills me as
well
so and then i have my cause my just
cause which is you know my why is where
i come from
my cause is where i'm going
and my cause is to create a world in
which the vast majority of people wake
up every single morning
inspired to go to work
feel safe wherever they are and then the
day fulfilled by the work that they do
you know that if you're going to put
stress into something that you get to
enjoy the fruits of your own labor you
know building something and looking at
and say i helped build that you know
that's a beautiful thing
and so
any work that i do is always to advance
that cause so there's a bunch of things
that i'm doing
some of which will work and some of
which will fail um i started a
my own imprint with penguin random house
oh really called optimism press amazing
where i'm looking for the people or
ideas that i believe need to be shared
that help move
uh the needle and advance towards that
cause
and so we've published
four books so far we have two coming on
the way
which is really exciting
uh how to make a plant love you
trust first
the power of giving away power and our
newest one is called partnering
and they all have a point of view about
how to move or new ideas about how to
advance this
closer towards this world that i imagine
so
um and all different takes on it which
is really fun
um so i have the imprint
um i'm working behind the scenes on
police reform
uh which has been intense and
fascinating and a steep education
also looking
um i'm doing some work to try and sort
of figure out how to drive innovation
inside large bureaucracies
so i'm trying to figure out i'm working
behind the scenes trying to work with
some really forward-minded
forward-minded
really
infinite-minded
young ceos or at least younger companies
to help them figure out how to build
infinite minded companies now it doesn't
matter if they sell it doesn't matter if
they have a liquidity event but they're
not driven by the sale they're not
driven by the liquidity event they're
driven to build a company that can
outlast them and they're driven to build
cultures that can withstand the test of
time and the loss of every single
employee
you know that you could have an entire
new generation come in and the company
will survive
um and so i really wanna i'm i'm looking
for those companies that i think are
worth
supporting and helping them build
a new kind of company for the next
generation because i think the way we've
been doing it for the past
30 40 years has been
really not helpful to the economy into
the world and i think that we have to
find new ways to do it in other words
i'm putting my money where my mouth is
i'm all the books that i've written
about these things i'm going to try and
get under the hood and try and help
these companies do it
your brilliance you know i saw it in the
list of all the things you're doing
you're brilliant but i also see it in
all the work you've created i see in the
content you put out there your
brilliance is very obvious i sat here
with the the guy that trained uh michael
jordan for 15 years and then he trained
kobe afterwards and he said that with
our brilliance often comes what he
refers to as like our dark side which is
the things we struggle with and those
and he says they there tends to be a
relationship between our brilliance and
our struggle or our dark side
are you aware of what your dark side is
in terms of the cost of your brilliance
well i think um
first of all i don't think i'm brilliant
i know that sounds
sort of like
falsely humble but i really don't think
of myself that way i genuinely think of
myself as an idiot and
and i'm not being glib at all i
i don't really understand very complex
things
um
and i have pretty bad adhd and so
everybody thinks i'm extremely read and
the reality is i've written more books
than i've read
and
and
i just i love the idea of reading i i
don't i can't read i don't read i learn
by listening and talking
and so uh um and so very complex things
my brain doesn't work that way and so i
i've learned to ask lots and lots and
lots of questions
so that something can be simplified to
the level that i can understand it and
if it's simple
and i can understand it that means i can
repeat it and so my books are my ability
to understand complex things by asking
other people lots and lots and lots of
questions so i can simplify it enough so
that other people can understand these
complex things too talk about biology
and anthropology of you know all kinds
of you know things that yes i know that
i've oversimplified them i'm fully aware
you know like people who criticize you
know criticize me like this is pop
culture you know pop science i know that
but if i make it it's full complexity
all i've done is written a textbook well
that's not helpful is it
so i don't think of myself in the way
that you receive my work
you know and i think that maybe the
impact of my work may be perceived as
genius but let us not confuse that the
impact of the work that may be perceived
as genius doesn't make the person who
produced it the genius right so i i
reject i'm flattered by but reject the
the
the compliment even though it's a gift
i'm supposed to gift yeah yeah um uh
take your gift back it has no use here
um so when you ask me like what's the
balance of genius genius being this
thing off the scale all the way far away
over there well if i don't think of
myself or even live my life that way
then the balance of something is
probably a little closer to the middle
so do i have darkness of course i have
darkness you know uh do i find that
darkness absolutely fascinating i do
what is it uh
the
i mean
a lot of my insecurities
uh that i'm
that i've dealt with some of like i've
it
i don't think i've ever actually said
out loud on a podcast like this
i might have mentioned a couple times
scarily like people would always ask me
um so simon what books are you reading
or what books are in your bedside table
well i can answer that question because
i have a pile of about five or six books
on my bedside table and i've read none
of them but they've been sitting there
for like two years
i've read some of two of them
i honestly don't remember the last book
i finished
other than my own because i had to read
it for the book on tape you know for the
audiobook
um
and so i would always answer that
question i would name one of the books
or i just named one of my perennial
favorites like oh man search for meaning
you know
and only now i'm sort of getting
comfortable with the idea of saying out
loud i don't read books and not because
i don't like them it's because i
struggle to
the good news is i learned how to learn
without them
i wish i could read because there's so
much good stuff in them and i know that
they go into level of depth that i
really want to understand but there you
go
and i think that goes to the honesty
thing you know i'm realizing that me
trying to answer the question
and avoid embarrassment
um
[Music]
it's valuable for people who like to
read books but for the people who
struggle to read books i just made them
feel worse
you know and somebody pointed that out
to me it's like every time i lied about
i never lied they said what books you're
reading said well this is on my bedside
table
um or i believe this book is important
you know or i just picked up this new
book which should all be true
i just didn't read them
that there's a group of people who also
struggle to read for whatever dyslexia
or add or whatever it is and and
i'm i'm living proof that you can do
okay without it now that doesn't mean
you can't learn
but you gotta find the hack
there's a couple books i finished
um i finished
i finished the davinci code
it's so good
and it's you know why because it's
written with really really really short
chapters
like three pages that's i'm the person
who like always looks pages ahead to see
how much i have to go and if it's like
50 pages i'm like yeah how does that
change how you write though if you if
you're not a reader yourself
when you're ironic isn't it yeah that i
yeah it's ironic that i ended up writing
books
writing is a it's a it's different um
because if it's really fun when i'm
editing because if i'm boring myself i
just
cut that whole section
and so
the books have my sense of humor in them
like there's little jokes in there
because it makes me giggle
and i write about the things that i
think are really interesting i tell the
stories that make me
interested and and i can make myself cry
with some of those stories in the book
and i can give myself goosebumps with
some of the stories in that book and if
i'm doing it for myself it's probably
working for others too
you know um
but i i do love ideas
and i love
dissecting ideas and understanding ideas
and i really love understanding why
things work i am a little kid at heart
you know i want to know why
um not as a noun as i popularized it
would start with why but as a question
like why is it that way i'm really i
love that question it is
it is a little kid question you know and
for some reason as adults we stopped
asking and started just blindly
accepting and that doesn't mean i have
to be rebellious in the question it's
not it's not an accusation like why are
you doing it that way
it's genuine curiosity like why does it
work that way
and i love that and when i discover
things that are
illuminating to me
and i'm able to explain it to my friends
my friends can understand these things
and the joy i see in people's faces and
when they when i challenge their
perspective
then the the fun is to share it
well i'm going to give you your the gift
back
of brilliance thank you the reason why i
think i do use the word brilliance is
because
you meet people sometimes that have one
of the three believe you use the word
genius
um if you meet people sometimes you have
like one of the what i consider to be
the holy trinity of like affecting
change as an orator sometimes they have
wisdom sometimes they're like good
storytellers and then sometimes that
they have the delivery but you rarely
meet people that have all three your
delivery in terms of when you deliver
ideas the way you can like punctuate
sentences and the tone of it keeps
people incredibly engaged and i think
you gave me
the root cause of that when you said you
had adhd and you're a bad reader because
you find it hard to hold
you find it hard for other things to
hold your attention so you're very good
at holding the attention of someone else
listening and then the circuitous way in
which you deliver a point as well makes
incredibly engaging from a storytelling
perspective and then the wisdom or the
simple idea that underpins it that we
can understand because i've sat here
before and honestly we've deleted
podcasts because someone comes in
they're a genius mathematician yeah but
when you ask them to make that complex
math idea relevant and resonant in my
own life it's impossible we deleted the
episode because they're too smart to
like to simplify for sure um but you're
able to do that that's why your books
are so important and that's why
all the content you put out online and
on your youtube channels and instagram
is so necessary we have a closing
tradition on this podcast where
the last guest asks a question for the
next guest oh cool so they wrote it in
the story they don't know who they're
writing it for i love that and you when
you write your question you also don't
know who you're writing it for but it's
our way of all the guests talking to
each other that's great and a long
linear scene do i get to know who's
asking you don't i don't okay
what was
the happiest moment of your life so far
the happiest i literally can't answer
the question it's for me it's
my happiness doesn't exist in the past
it's i've done many things that made me
happy but i'm much more
interested in what's going to happen
next
i'm probably better at answering the
question what's the happiest thing
you're going to do
um i i'm i'm actually drawing a blank
what is the happiest thing you're going
to do
um
walked into that one didn't i
um the happiest thing i'm going to do
is
actually solve some of the problems
and or at least contribute to the
solution of some of those problems that
we talked about
like i will be very happy when i help
when i can contribute to police reform
in this country
i will be very happy
when i can
figure out
better systems to help
reinvent
what modern business looks like and
reject everything that jack welch built
you know
and
disrupt
shareholders supremacy and the way that
we build companies now i will be very
happy to demonstrate a momentum towards
an entirely different direction
um i will be very happy
um
if all of the sum of my work
makes it feel like i have moved the
needle somewhat closer
though not final towards that vision i
talked about of an inspired safe and
fulfilled world ironically those sound
like infinite games many of them yeah i
don't believe i mean
all of the things that will make me
happy will be incomplete
i
i don't expect them to be complete what
will bring me joy
like when when you if let me rephrase
the question for myself
which is how will you know you lived a
life worth living
it's kind of the same question right
and the answer will be is because
other people will pick up where i left
up and continue without me
that i
was clear enough
my cause was compelling enough
and the tools that i left were sharp
enough that others figured out how to
not only use them but make them better
and reinvent new ones
i will have lived a life worth living if
i can look back and say it will keep
going without me
because it doesn't need me
and that's the goal
simon thank you
it's a huge honor and a pleasure and it
it's very clear why you were probably
the most requested guest on this this
podcast um from our from our viewers and
you've definitely given much more than
um i could have ever hoped for in terms
of your generosity and wisdom to me but
also to our listeners in this
conversation so thank you so much for
your generosity simon thank you it's
it's been a joy um
and you
it's one of the best podcasts i've ever
done i mean
you are so engaging and driven your
cause comes out clear which is you are
so driven by the truth
you are so compelled by the truth that
anybody sitting here
really wants to offer only truth
um
and
it's a cause worth fighting for
thank you i will accept the gift
we are all looking for ways to live a
little bit more sustainably and to make
more conscious choices in our day-to-day
routines so when a brand like my energy
who i've spoken about before offered to
sponsor this podcast i felt like and i
knew deep down inside that i had to help
them share their mission to create an
even greener world it feels like there's
not much more fulfilling than that and
their products provide an easy and cost
effective way to make a sustainable
switch in your life and they've got some
existing new products coming out that i
can't wait to use myself and i'll let
you know as i use those products how i
get on so if you're a my energy customer
at the moment let me know your favorite
products down below in the comments
section and if you haven't checked them
out yet go to myenergy.com and find out
a lot more about who they are and what
they're doing if you're one of those
people that wants to make a sustainable
switch
myenergy.com is the place for you
[Music]
[Music]